there's this question i have about when
someone's encountering the phenomenon
let's imagine this occurs to one of the
people watching
do you have advice given from all that
you know and all of the people you've
spoken to like lou for example should
someone's approach it stay away run away
stop i would not take someone directly
afterwards should they not wash their
clothing because that's residual
evidence on it i see i see like a crime
scene um well first thing is i wouldn't
approach it
right because you know you don't know
what it is you know just just because
you see a glowing ball of something
doesn't mean it's an alien it could be
bald lightning you know rare as it is
and that could be you know that's a
purely terrestrially explainable
phenomenon at some level and you you
might hurt yourself
so
you know and then i i just wouldn't
approach it and i would save everything
that you can
um and
i think writing down your thoughts at
the moment is probably the most
important thing
because remembering things years later
you fill in the gaps
so you know
write it down but also i would also say
don't believe everything you see
right um just because you see something
doesn't mean
it's
actually there
you know there's
there are enough stories about people
who feel that these things are
projections
right that uh
so maybe something projected into an
individual's mind
again this is all conjecture and i again
i want to warn the various skeptics who
love to write little nasty grams about
me
um
you know i'm not uh a born and true
believer
i
uh i'm interested in finding out what
the truth is
about these things uh
i feel that given that there are enough
individuals who seem to report seeing
the same things
or experiencing the same things that
there's a story here
that needs to be explained it's either
mass hysteria
some form of jungian
collective
unconscious
kind of thing or it's or it's something
real but then once you get to the it's
something real how real or unreal is it
and again if you if people are familiar
with
um john keel and jacques uh primary
theses
on this
that it's
you know there's there's an element of
irre irreality to this that has yet to
be understood
it drives me crazy
you know thinking about it um
and
anybody especially with jacques
uh with the background and knowledge
about what it is that that jacques
involves himself with is he's always
looking for what's behind the what's
behind
right that what you're presented
is
um as he often has called it a form of
kabuki theater
right it's it's it's something which is
meant
to be an intermediary or a stand-in
for an objective
right that these beings or whatever the
people claim that is that they see
aren't necessarily
the the beings or the or the
consciousness as you're interested in
that's actually driving the process that
there's something put there
in the stead of
whatever this higher level consciousness
is
as an intermediary and i had a long
discussion about this i think on the lex
friedman show for people who want to you
know talk about that the whole the the
ants and how do you communicate with
ants right right i'll leave a link to
that in the description